[Music]
the students i work with come in with
all different skill levels
relating to chess so it's really
challenged me as a teacher to
adapt my teaching style to kind of be
appropriate for all students while also
trying to get them this
camaraderie as it relates to chess and
do group activities i started playing
chess this year because at first i
thought chess was like really boring and
i didn't really understand it
but being in the class kind of
changed my perspective on it and i
really want to stay in chess now
i didn't know the difference between a
good move and a bad move and over time i
slowly saw the difference between a good
and bad move i need to take my
my mind off of something that's pretty
hard i just think about chest or
think about a game that i just had the
other day
[Music]
when i got a win and then i just think
about how much joy i felt in that moment
and if they can have that moment in
chess where they solve a tactic or they
find the checkmate i feel like it
enhances their confidence and it shows
that when we see one move look for a
better move and i kind of think about
that when i'm playing chess like if i
see one good answer should i look
for a better answer chess has helped me
in school
by
teaching me how to approach different
problems like in math or science
uh chess is awesome because we got a
cool teacher he's very chillax
he doesn't he takes things seriously i
like it
i feel like chess has had an enormous
impact on the students i've worked with
this year because i've worked with the
same students
predominantly the whole
year and so i've seen students come
come to me at the beginning not knowing
anything about chess to kind of pushing
an 1100 rating on lee chess
where they
can describe certain tactical motives uh
certain opening strategies
they're very aware of kind of outside
cultural elements of chess they can
probably rattle off five grand masters
so they've really kind of gone from
square one to
uh probably intermediate level i would
say
so usually every class period uh
we start off with a
tactical training and so usually i'll
put on a tactic and sometimes it'll be a
struggle for about five minutes and
people are
describing different ideas different
moves
and then you just kind of see it in
their eyes and usually i'm like shh
because we want everybody else to try to
have that moment too but it's really fun
because it's kind of like you're in on a
secret until everybody figures it out
pursuing chess as a player
um
helps with your
strategy your decision making outside of
chess
a lot of times students will try to pop
in my class and get a game and i come to
find out that now they're playing games
over lunch or maybe sometimes in other
classes when they're not supposed to be
i get to play against my friends
experience loss
and
i get to experience victory
i've learned how to look at problems
differently like every chess player has
a way of playing
and
you just have to find your way of
playing we come up with candidate moves
and chess well if i do if i play my
night to this square
what could my opponent um
do in that scenario and i think it gets
us thinking in our world if i
if i go and engage in this
what's going to happen or if if i study
for a test versus not study it's it gets
them thinking in different ways uh which
i
a lot of times they'll come to me and
talk about outside of chess issues
they're they're going through and it
seems like they're
being very diligent and uh pragmatic
about their decision making
i i'm sure that if my little brother
learns more about it he will love chess
just as much as i do
[Music]
you